we are joined today by Renegade SEC
commissioner Hester purse late of the
mercatus center she has written a very
interesting dare I say blistering
critique of a recent decision by the SEC
the Securities and Exchange Commission
could you talk just a little bit about
the structure of the SEC for people who
don't understand it you know this
commissioner system I've read your work
on this I know you were actually an
advocate of that system and now as
someone who's you know inside of it what
is that like being you know on a Board
of Commissioners who you know disagree
on topics and and how does that form or
how does that affect the the ultimate
decision-making process yeah I mean
there are five of us and the chairman
sets the agenda manages the staff but
and and so we have less input on on sort
of the rules that we're going to be
doing and so forth but we all have a
voice and the idea is that you want to
have people from different perspectives
because you want to have some policy
consistency over time we we all vote on
every enforcement action and on every
rulemaking
um I you know people sometimes say to me
well has to do nothing except for talk
about things so why don't you just
resign and I think the point is and
other people say to me well someone who
is a skeptical of Regulation as you are
shouldn't even be at a regulator and my
response is I think it's really
important to have people with different
voices saying we need to look at these
things from a different perspective and
um you know sometimes it takes a long
time to shift the thinking but I think
it's it's worth having
um people sort of debating these things
rather than just
coming out with one view I mean the
world is very complicated and there's
there's more than one way to look at
things uh we've got two questions for
you and we're going to let you go at 1
30. um first can you building on that
what is your general theory of good
regulation in the financial sector um
you know as when you were working at the
mercatus center at George Mason uh you
wrote a lot you were a fierce critic of
sarbanes-oxley and Dodd-Frank uh the
last two Mega kind of uh you know pieces
of legislation on the financial sector
what does good regulation look like
um you know if you know if you were able
to write that well I think the first my
first principle is that if two people
voluntarily agree that they want to do
something there needs to be a very good
reason for the government to step in
into that transaction and say no you
can't do that or you have to do it
differently there are times when the two
people's agreement to do something can
have of consequences for other people
outside of that transaction we have to
be thinking about that
um so my my gen that's my general
philosophy I I think we need to make
sure that people's incentives
um
are match up with consequences right so
if you if you if you take a step that's
a stupid step and you lose a lot of
money the government shouldn't be coming
in to prevent you from losing it
um and unfortunately that has happened a
lot in our financial system and it's
sort of changed the way everything works
and it's LED government to come in and
say Well since we're bearing the
consequences when people make stupid
decisions we're going to try to make
decisions for them but because
government doesn't have the right
incentives it's very difficult for
government to make decisions effectively
markets are much more effective at
conveying information than a regulatory
system is and so we need to capitalize
on that we need to take advantage of the
fact that markets transmit information
really well so that my my theory is
always yeah there's a place for
regulation but it shouldn't be the first
place we look it should be the last
place what what does a good regulation
or what what's an example do you think
of a good regulation that actually
reduces transaction costs without
distorting you know behaviors I think we
can play a role in helping people get
disclosure to make their own decisions
about things
um so and and certainly you know there
are rules around mutual funds that I
think have been effective rules
um there there are a lot of things the
SEC does that I think do help reduce
transaction costs
but I think too often we try to just
jump in and make a merit-based decision
based on our understanding of someone
else's circumstances and I find that
really offensive there's kind of the
inevitability that Regulators are going
to try to regulate you mentioned some of
the issues that arise there with kind of
they get comfortable with incumbent
firms and then makes it harder for new
entrants so this was all meant to
disrupt that whole system is there a
case for just saying okay if the SEC
wants to put out some sort of
registration form and make it optional
and let people who want to opt in to
only the SEC approved versions that's
fine but just let crypto be crypto and
people can kind of enter at their own
risk
yeah and I certainly understand that
point of view but I think we have the we
have rules on the books and to the
extent that whether it's crypto or
something else those implicate the
existing rules then we have to enforce
those rules now if you're talking about
do we want to develop a new regulatory
framework where there really are gaps
and where things really aren't covered
that's a conversation that we should be
having and I think one of the things I
always say is don't jump to the
conclusion that regulation is going to
be the answer to solving problems I mean
a lot of the problems we saw with
centralized entities in the crypto World
during the last year are problems that
are very similar to problems we see with
we've seen with traditional Financial
intermediaries but there also are things
that people can do on their own to hold
those intermediaries accountable and as
and as people working at intermediaries
they can do things to show people that
they're that that they're doing what
they're saying they're doing so people
in crypto shouldn't be jumping to the
conclusion that regulation is is always
the first and best answer
we have to have this conversation as a
community you know I'm maybe on on one
side of the spectrum and and saying look
let's let's figure out whether there's a
better way to do this but there are
other people who are very much committed
to having a regulatory solution and
that's just something in this in this
Society we got to work out
um and figure out where most people are
it's really important for people who are
in crypto to think about you know
applying the lessons from traditional
Finance right and thinking about that
thinking about you know if you're really
trying to build something decentralized
what does that actually look like
and then sort of thinking about whether
it makes sense to say
let's try to carve out the decentralized
world and figure out whether and really
make the pitch that regulation is not
wouldn't play the same role there
because the decentralization the
on-chain aspects the fact that everyone
can participate on the same terms that
actually takes the place of Regulation
it's harder to make that case when
you're talking about large centralized
intermediaries that are holding people's
assets so it is important to think about
where are the spaces where people just
want to be able to say yes I'm opting in
to a less regulated space I'm certainly
open to something like that I don't know
whether you know others in Washington
are but I but I think you know everyone
goes in Eyes Wide Open you create a
choice to operate in a space that has
less regulation than other spaces hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from
our live conversation with SEC
commissioner Hester purse and crypto
investor and writer Nick Carter about
the government's escalating Crackdown on
cryptocurrency exchanges like Kraken and
the broader defy economy join me and
nicolespie here every Thursday at 1pm
Eastern for more conversations like this
and subscribe to recent's YouTube
channel for notifications whenever our
videos go live
thanks for watching